ми живимо у всіх таза розбивати цю
трансляцію дойче велле українську
української редакції аніматика мовляв не до
дочка було б назвати цей фільм я
журналістка кийок порожній але я думаю
на 3 уявляв то я все одну задував і
німці зрубаю цех там стоїть аблаєва
який же сер карен ви директор
кримського дому з чилійського служба вас
видно не дуже багато наварила дарина
просто будь ласка коментарі тема і
нібито ви себе являв і чоловіки
вб'єш коректно не одружуються забула
вона вирішила золото я почну все-таки з
Дорі Дорі ми kohana люди тону на допомогу
і а не земне це ковток видається годині
для того щоб
просто його розум а сьогодні дістати
призначай нас матричний день та
молодість за різними даними розум
яхти з тобою fresh сер оттар прудіус
арт-директор каннського будинку ви владні
все сказала майстер 2 потрібні нахильник двох
курсів театральними що ці культури
людина
йдуть динаміку багата українців знають і
поважають мої так сказати що ви сповнені
аспірантура це також давайте
прогуляємося крихтою я поки я поясню.
нашим для дач людина буває
деми зараз ми били андріївської церкви
спускається знову і художники завитки
арно панорама на qi відкривається тушки з
нижчого ми покажемо
чому ми сьогодні зібралися думаю і
відразу мала тому що сьогодні особливою видай
для україни для кожного українця для нас
весну я не знаю що називається сьогодні
збираємо тому що з одного боку день
на закладеності ясна важливі вода за
меншого букву c черемнів і в руку вигляд
колою пуджа лося повномасштабні в
туркменії русія євро як україна за знаючи
багачів радий я до хвилин наші воїни the man
адже вона й не спробує
мова вибір це щось світляк висловить
сьогодні почет для нас для вас але я би
спробував би побільше однозначно
раджу а ви хочу прояснити
сутність незалежності
вона на емоціях на імена це закладено
[музика]
методики
ідеї обидва вам якийсь порядок довжини нам
хочеться поставити ти де ж українці ареса
на сьогодні з так і
бан від обороту руки в гості мова
московський який і russia with a що він
домагається нас захисту сама суть несли
закладеності id24 церкви як символ як
можна ви календарним датам такі важливі
емоції ми спарювання люду їдеш до в'їзду
сам зціленим, бо у дітей шкірні
любимо і я на ім'я маркери далекі
призначаються та nadir & shami та ноги майже
тягнути in ідея дату та
календарі і тому сама сотні сказав
області не доманова на зміну олег
шива сотні табору закладеності одружуватися
лицедійство свята у вас але і
наперед чого
на нього в ніші зараз українця вболівати
свою свободу видимість свої узагальнення
свиту свої проблемні свої вправи до
вас на свого покладете з араду чим ми
класні буду його за раз вся україна за
раді все виводиться які будуть нападати
на циліндрі ояш випливає, а сьогодні
складуть у вас навіть армія святкова
броня український дії плану це
якось знаю рокестером заходи сімей
нечисть тільки
спраги хочеш
вони радше кримського лікарі станції теж
ми вже гуляємо
тут міг там і ви не так давно
повернулася саддукеїв описано тобою
відгули на фронті хоч провальну розумію
ну я б знаєш такі
[музика]
випробувавши
трохи розібрати c&c харчування оборону у
той же на фронті але для - та швидко
франція для порятунку без останній
зуль-хіджа
війни між освітлені оборотні сестри
кожен, ніж саме перебування близького
район полум'я бойова ідей згідно ж
фонд
так більше бери трьох місяців та умова
свого ризикову pedrollo бог вас посеред
а там до подобається
бойові день і ви по роботі з на така
повернулася а справа в тому, що бог
примарний покараний командира бригади
freeze нічні начальнику служби
viscose рама щастя наших бригади це
замовлення команди трубу в київ просто за
покараний командира але так ризиково служба
я залишився один і накласти але у цьому
контексті так моя ніби там уже як суд і
з відома та вільну для себе вирішив що за
1 по 3 ноти чи школа служба вівцям
поспішає шерл це мутація ну розширює
скажемо ось так і харчування вид поезії та
ідеї
артема пробуємо він воду паузу і я хочу
ще багата про вас особливі сто разів по 5
право шлях тільки покажемо і нашим
завданням придатна панораму на київ
є владна красиво українська столиця
спокійно сьогодні святкова я на році
нашим завданням що ти дуєш валу
українську що ми тому пряму
трансляцію з українською стоїте у довгій
закладеності на водою shots of tanks та
це було його та його дружина дарина і що я
журналіст підошвою ланофіл ми закінчили
нашу розгулу порвав її дружкою як
різному сенсі історіях тема тому що
у лютому 25 років ми на стіні розумі його
я активно став адаптер оборону
розкачати в 2 з яких і робота
рішення я як ви прийшли дати у вирішенні
наскільки вона була для вас складною
ну я пишу замовити чесно the
direction на сумував sc харчування до 4
лютого яскравіше вас ось ми ж таким самим
розумним не цими чуваками
14 з 20 столітті знаходимося в Сімферополі та
на у вас на краще
batch of окупацію криму в результаті особистий
стануть мемов зовсім на такі
потім і омега-6 хмари б при місце
користь на вигляд самсун і вранці травму на
зйомках нас знову фільми це не знав ніж
всі ходи тобто одне можна сказати
точно буде готовий мати повірити в те
що все-таки c персонаж учень су-7
конче
накластися
таку другу широкомасштабних виллю овець
залишилося впізнавати і майже газ парадності
все ж таки по гранади ж час
шини хоче і чого ти там і 25 історія до
обдзвонила своїх рідних близьких за розум
вище за всіх Господь і 25 у кримському домі
ми було розум здоров'ю
до нас прийняв сам Микола а й друг краще
стежка та
ми навіть дражний поїхав шиплять це місце
для малих записатися синду love будь
чого тероборони оксамитових
салютом
розумі ми поїхали всі імена живці місця та
сказати нам здавалося хлопці на
споживання степу нитки на ми летимо по
цим вже charger cable навчальний оружня
покерним а то що було роздала і там
приходьте завтра ну і що є ми
повернувся з ще одним другом із кримом
своїм пастирським тобто ми година минає
набір 1 батальйоні приїхав туди вже
через 2 води
підписала контракт відривалася брови ще
горище і підступний і чому чи сипить
відновлено і там потім і ночі три дні
до своєї ротації навіяти в пункт
нехай вона дислокації в катани
командиром
нашого pedrollo та примарні
прес-офіцер
ось так просто вчилася ще одна часом на
працює і небудь робот може і самі
шутер рабів у тому числі свій матері не
можете простіше крихти і лише спеціалізації
хочеш сказати йому просте, що чоловік вийшов
і до своєї команди та команди кримської
вдома та друзям з території кіно зате
США багатий скарбниці і
малювався потім за вишивки у Києві і ми
практично з 25 лютого фільм про нього
фіксу йому запишемо можемо за фірсова то ви
займає так портрети людей
документального поїдання факти
значення у Російській федерації рота
україни стала на сьогодні, але я нагадаю
що це скажу що скупився і ми коротші
вартістю майже на 15 робіт матеріалів
спектру шуму навіть за
міжнародними
партнерами йому на уазі кіл їх з тилу
каналів міжнародний дана але один
факт там через призму 2 ти ж їх краще
вибрати його ти спочатку команді разів
офіцер pedross було світлими наших битті
фанати міфи постерів заявився у таких
виданнях
your time ставимо з
reuters круто так я веду cm10 нашого
команди ну і таким членом і нам араміс
в тому числі ніби корисливими
екшену досягти і я до відео доводив
база для нього суду призначені я
хочеш зараз поверну 1000 разів до наших
ряду човен що у вас будуть у вона кота за
харчування з догляду нашої трансляції по
ходу нашого розмелювання 20 таких кімнатах
почали ж дряпати повідати мені я задам
нашими пастями затвори ним дарина яковлева
ландшафтом пішов у або вати 25
була ще й опинимося під кущем і вам
porsche дні нотація гаряча.
семашко виводить було через них
вливання в той же час було вирізано
гордості за нього я нас проведені знала
до самих інгур мені вчених через
кордон
[сміх]
я факти що вона спала і він був пишу
день будинку
ах ти мій вибір це що
б сумніви ясна в плані роботи
професора суке та
закрилися на роботу для батальйону для
засола чим у вас все-таки ви вирішили що
ви будете щурів нижчими на vine вони ж би
виклики шилась авось цивільному цивільному
можете режисеру на проект можна ось і
піни гарне харчування вінді зі мною
зуміє ставлю
включаючи це може що досить
багатою немає за його дальністю
пончик на плівках а engine на прямий кінці
минулого люди сідниці зовсім володію
людожер my students 150 людей та
у самого ті емоції ки-мен і був і 24
лютого всі уроку ці нагадав і
чи піші чогось у 27 лютого 14 року
якому на поліція була реальною і
вона вже майже безсилі і баз на радість
і ж на стеку і
навіщо відновити в язичну
обожнювання
за роботи в тому числі і здорово руках
шасі з конкретним broen хоч я
очевидно на менше порожнини і режимі
можлива при місце
вас посеред на полі бою на трушці engine
вона просто є постулатом друзі
спецназу а саме рублів там
де ти і максимуму старшого можеш стен
що
за розлучити по вітряно тривога доки ми
тут говоримо
вже мабуть 3 4 спритності.
ми на пологах від tak.ru б це нашим для
дачами км та за розробником
у мойому sage така у парку
metallica вигляд та кайфуєш літні у них
об'єктив ми з подіємо якщо наташа
свобода добра як там а я кажу це на
палітра всередині можу в Києві
я б сказав уже
широко шини
може на площину
але краще це саму музику з дому
сирами
це плеча це я візьму залежно
складаєш все-таки
зарубін і яко багата руках травня та носіння
на музиці у тому числі
спрямованого на таку та травня but i
батрака ти і сун і
страх
[музика]
ланцюг на пробій знав то не пощастило
додам сам таїнство батарейки травня
до місця та мати іншу інформацію кожному
довжини шорти можуть і призначаючи на
образним нічого доброго чорним цін цієї
звуки і кібер хочуть завалити блазні також
вологому на місці і тамашіі стінки
асоціації
шириною різьблених з рідних натискань
на моєї дружини добрий стеба вивіз почався
рано 24 цього феномену було здається сара
було б було й шпилькою чи щось
було червона сарен нагадаю той лазарус що
проблем ну ти нарешті ми тут
нападали до андріївського спуску на і
художники тут людей на багатого
чоловіки ось ми що тут увечері зазвучали
люди збираються обрали сьогодні центром
місця проїжджали я за зростання обстановка
через розквіт і
але ми дію буквально проїжджали та
кричати люди бачіли так можна ви на так
багата
я була на ринку годинник all i play ну і
чому сьогодні навіть спектр на зрозумi що
ви чергова версія та особі бытошь
хочеш за клік це людей мені розумієш я
сам посібник початківцям продуватися
нехай і ну в середу де ви але все-таки
випробування і тому просто хочеш
здаватися щоб призначаємо обороні та
навіть заплакала і володар голландської
запаювання у нас вже на 1 і на пари донів
торгова і наша розвідка говорила його з
османські хати розсилав і так що на і
світу це на 24 на 23 серпня наруто
сигнали по вітрини та тривога чоловіків або
провокації ну top to take a trophy на
пружинному зведену сьогодні ситуація
лякати the sun та там скоро ту роботу над
рамосу скрізь лайки я за барони не то тут
є такі вишивається всі чекають і кайф
з масштабних провокацій та друзів та
чого ви дуже клаве сьогодні випинає а
сьогодні себе забезпечена тут у стоїте і
ви автор травня ви дари що що ми будемо
це йди воду
блок
на природі сказати що
переживаєш себе повністю без пенсії
сьогодні безпосередньо на травень на практичну
жадібного у . наші околиці до за взяття в
лапках
путіну та птахи
bio масі
ти не можеш своїми чого ти немов
спеції дружини. нашої вкрай
те, що відчувається емоції крижини
страшного не страшно мая ніби страшно
бо це ти їси
сублімати свої страх
в у читаннях порозуміння там грядку день обидва
те що
ти знаєш
аналізу їж і ситуаціям у смуги ми і
там де знаходишся
ті c важливо rich як шо ти пам'ятаєш зону
закохаєшся
атмосферу страху
вас не жити їм потрібен
століття на мінівен у тому числі правильне
тон щоб жадібних валентиновичу wars і б
люди ну і як може жити і відпочивати і
нагадаю наче або теж баночок
забувається тобто називається так про з
виду тобто
піддам незрозумілому страху червона точна
що ціни тобто там річки травня буду
природі для кожного виду тому що ж
так по стінах страх у
батьки на можна його не треба Іван їм не
брудняться вісь ножа а ось так сталося
багатих теж українців безпосередньо світові
сюди туго завжди тобто
можна ви за професію своїх та й по
номеру звук головне не думають і що ти
згадай без пальці валуни на 5 тис і так
ось чого такого видного врахуєш його ти не
буду ходиш тобою там все можна чи
захист і до найрозумнішого захисту закритий
Всевишнього алли в багнети ніби пан йому
важливим давайте собі роду на порівняти з
того що тобі може бути страшно vc
нормально з природою своєю красою
Ці інструментарі давали часто риту і
люди ну
на джгути, що тішать подальшого травня
мобілізовані травня джгути важливим марш
назад нарешті століття будуть безтурботними
для теми або твої диски тут ви правду
сказала щоб від токто важливий, адже
можуть тут у співачка просто вич і вається
вчора я гуляла кришка так сумуючи
через свої роботи і там було стільки
людей і просто спокійно сабіха ти
виконаєш все за родом спала на і
російської техніки і до наріжте
дістався дах такий
флоту до бачу тягнули у все закінчилося
дуже у нас, правда, нічого не закінчилося
далеко що його 5 щоб що закінчилася
відривають обстріли хорькова на клавіші на
сокир на сьогодні прокату у миргороді
збув ракету на черкаську область
відриваючи дай нам уже кровопролитного
відразу і на спів вину сотні людей від тут
можливість заміж такі на батога церква і
брови трохи обидва спайки тому що тут
ніхто не може жити в страху ви зараз
ви розважаюсь і яскравість адаптується
вже давно увійти хіральності таке ми за
пиріг та а пацани початкового звучало ми
порох витягла
знає про матч честь і зате досить
багатою я тобі познайомитися без
побудови на лінії земними ти розумієш
його чого їж що біля стінки правда треба
жити і
прання абсолютно свідомий
їстівного бочками себе у світлі своїх
pray своїх плані сном небудь не і
вона зараз люди і
адже він там забив і водам
розпадом ноти у Києві а потім думаю
врізних місця ж людей мишкою і акту ну
приблизно tsm джордж що у вас стало
тепло там дівчата ходить у таких вбраннях
обидва будинки класно там батіку там такі
врахуєш що-небудь лавини на травень інназі
все-таки середовища нарядами та абсолютним
більшості своїй у тих розмах
доходить до того що так c здорово так і
травня but та тому що c ви краще
зараховано нашого жити та зайчика владно
або там знаходиться в юті ви буревіч інша
справа США
скажімо у кого ти назвав його і
такі пінний розумна крыша та й закриватися
себе ось новим закривалася від ситуації
падику збуваються нанесли ж видається
c неправильному чесно та
нібито людина домагалася а but і поза
його політичними процесами подобається і
трагедія
он вона зможе
but i гострим тому що ти їм обом
що йшов нам з закопати шкірного я виходжу
схоже до чого виставку
заново простого і навіть по вч вони ну і
вікна міни виставку
натиснути
до них з моїх колег до початку та
широкомасштабної фази провини та мозес доби
чого солідно ще
але ми в тілі прийшов культура через
політику
що їхнім гастролям кумир тивні виступи в
вкрай агресоре та злодії варварів цінам
agony я не буду до місць та даних
українську душу в українську емоцію і не
буду таким членом
1 холод і з ближ нями ціни правда це
dei багата мої друзі та я в тому числі
здавалося, що тими словами забив
прикривають
[музика]
просто до обожнювання зарубає і в витрати ти
ринок для мої парфуми
роботи алла цінника змушені
німа не розуміє а хто ти і хто ти і я
щось не даси за тій та й кит у мене
Всевишній асами mako та худий шапку багато 2
3 тисячі противників геть і вірити втб
он і вважають досить часто тебе як
модель за для
падуба не я король його модель поєдинку
кохані та
навішую нічого такого свій внесок і
дальність за те, що таке було даровано
владно наводить datastore чекати його
універ пролітаємо
натиснули а вам потрібно так і патріна щоб
люди боролися що
вина так
вона сама букана шкода
тупа шкіра раніше можливого своїх
danish лярна того щоб вріжте бій
ваша культура з самого місяця найпід
потрібні інструментарій для того, щоб
розігріти не пустувала харчування до з
еньші культури та шива контексту я кував
але ванну чого так
вони шт і
так cfc чисельний погляд абсолютно
верховний за допомогою шкіра людина безуважно
на якій посаді який чудовий
приналежності конфесій най
приналежності відповідно до результату
культурного петровича цього культурного
калу на цьому нарадіє зростаючий ранок
мою почет приклади для
успадкування ну миж нагадаю
black ви ймовірністю до можемо
представити і голос цей кулька шоу для
ти не натішиться в полі
таке громади до віку головним
постулатом то їх те падає і що в не
право сильного
для друзі всі справи і в закон ті люди на
шляхи мого зростання в таке кохання але
політика не знаю
журналіст тора режисери які буду і
проводять та scp
каширин поважаючи дистанційним дам жити
через творчість через свої дороги та
через ухвалення законів ну і на такі
глибини
гострим і знання про ти шиї чудово
носіння що
гуманістичним у своєму складі та свої
голови нашого друга поряд знаю точно і в
небо і земля знаю точно що
ти миєш торренти вона вийняла ти щось
тикет cm можна їсти владно для нагадав
us зручного житія тому культура форева
кожного дня із самою логікою
інструментарій безкровний і сам мати і
ми маємо одягаємося що сама
культурно складу так писали
закінчення війни якщо нашої пари
модниця вірно
будеш художниці в Україні, але явно я б
Англія вашого залишилося 3 у неї є 100
нових
стратегій надійним каменем фундаментами
хочеш ти не через розвиток за
став хіба українці
практично точно говорить а ви плану це
пара творить і так спочатку знімали на
прокладати зараз накину обидва що
зайняті просіть якісь лютого ну владно
переїхали за ми займаємо 25
валюта
виходити з умів
ситуації число та кому ж але ми будинок думав
з клавіш його займаємо вона все шиї під
рукою тобто а мені година палати 6 більше
цього фон на телефон так хочеш на палець
а б за вишивайся телефон камера кілька
телефоні в кито камера планшет будь про
шоу ти б їй в руках ось за російську
момент півлітра великий зафіксовано
не можеш сказати що людина шуваєва
того матеріалу йти
стають якраз нас і а я як художник
зустрічку скариж як ну досить було
чесно
скажімо на
обер них портретів не буду жива українці
резонанс соціального прожарювання різьблених
професії визнаного віку
ти що точно відпочиваючи
що досить часто ти чуєш, проте ви і
думки
про найважливіші харчування all або людей
ці набрані жити і невеликий протон
вузи та
цінами на свічки на те що ось на ім'я
такі фундаментальні народ і ви на
хвилі та шар у палітрі топ топ 1 особисто
їм
досить вали контакті частина людей у
україні і в тому числі за зміт ​​маса
інформації щоб
я прошу за
можна гордовитий пафос то
лавина і вина бути і держава творча
контекст та думки
різьблених людей і ти вийде ти розумієш
так на твоїх ділянках сьогодні в ранці
мовчати розгулятися за блаженними
писанням чому ти бачила таку давид і
весь там друзі чистими додаєш
слухаємо джеку і чуєш такі самі dunkey
справила там 1 2 тиху так вони
забруднюється можна його людяним і
нагадаємо розуму нитки до
словникового запасу яхта до жити а в самому
головному ти приколюєшся що
вона прям це ясна живеш лише частина ж
ти в години і на вибач і трагічні а ви
все-таки проживання живучи
цокали годинник ми бажаємо я витають їх туди
їжу та саду нашої трансляції на дощ та
ми будемо її кицькою вас гавкіт художники
вчені падали до андріївської церкви
надуєш сьогодні знаємо їх ах там саїд
аблаїв та тягу до хана дар'я та тягну фільм
журналістка довше валу став то свої,
не я поки що руйнуються романі повідомляють
що дадуть нових захід вони мої малюки
купап обожнюю здоров'я
ви зламані не було 2 ст.
задоволений нашим гостям. вище теж нам не
для дачі я хочеш приєднатися Тетяна. їм
shoot em up що дозволь це поворот та
про крим
тому що астані ми станемо і ти ж ним
і душа багата піди і адже там буває тут
ж таких тикових
безславне тут небо гівни так він і дуже
погано плитку it'sa рідше на bespeco
ну 6 риба
[музика]
їм якщо ти шаман і правильно роблять
знищу поки що нас тут за пожежну
bespeco
обличчя та владного ще раз
Петра g
людина підлога ти по людських він і не
можете
ну мої м'язи травня травня kbc крихта на наш з
провалу сторінка наша справа без
останній так і абсолютного праві крим
абсолютно наші справа всякого бочата
підступна крима писали про 8 роки в піт
покупець
ножа навряд чи можемо вказати про такі
варіант we come up
Волоча дружина просто роль мінералів
не снись скроні тут ви ризиковий шию алло
алло і ті самі санкції міжнародний
писк
інформаційно вина і кун світу сумувала і
адже люди стоїмо біля алли точно про можемо а
ось вся cs тут є і
restoration c-walk прирекли на нашому кінці
криму
не знаю не знала що вибивається що все
ставити сотки
манер мішок nsi в криму шакали і на
російський світ ціни правда думає про там
шкідливих ламаючи 8 8 ripsaw та й ми ножі
пізнання в мережі руки яким їм
зв'язок я сам на моя можна ввести навіть
Давид років ніби на малій батьківщині
користі алое але ми не видається я володію
достатню гнучкість у інформації друзів
вікторівна чого те що саме вибивається
віці настрої що там за що там за
ролики там від самої заразної країни
поліфонічний я би сказав тому що
знову боці
целестина правда підвищені чарлі до річки
люди із того, хто забив
тих хто приїхавши по стане годину проїхавши до
крима топ tuskar залишившись
загибеллю
анексію
зневажання прав людей землю дітей у тому
числі проїхавши жити до бірж тощо. регіон
ну ти впав на рив'єру і в польшу 1 щоб
жити ціни там вже Іван і науково зовсім
трохи побачила
щось можна буде і на
мою думку c справа вирішені наріжте
підшивається budgets на владний кращий
джерки відтінки підсідають безпосередньо на
мого абсолютно суб'єктивну думку
прямо і не в роті над із сином поспішають
з клініки міст він виходити на мій
залишатися праворуч ти до священних і
авторитетних людей
генштабі обраний сил україни
аліман відпочиваєш а
чи задоволені які пензлі
окупантів сама тушки залаз на вулиці ти
б спа стріляючих до чого і люди
приводять але дбайливо смуг а не бур'янам
та й
абсолютно вірна історія з них у торнані
до нашої України он і самі забираються
всередину і зобов'язана чого нам завмирає і
попий український мені місце хай
виїжджають звучиш лише у плач
сьогодні здається чим чого різного було по
вигляд він наніс білгородській області що
там мені теж спромоглася формулювання
Міноборони Росії чим саме піддається
зараза називають правильну продовжимо
білгородської області сама займанням
бійся складу з боєприпасами за гриж якщо
ти розвиваєшся що сама увага на
кімнату ж добрі і докладно променя ж
ми слова хімію отримують
так ну так і бувають такі бувають коли ти
живеш і x путіна у чині наше бідний і на
такі бувають тому, що Всевишній
все побачити з
а
всі моделі свою оцінку і назначає
кожному свої наша справа до слуху тис до
нього та
в лапках допомагає і
think the
в 4 чайники жадібні живі люди не мати
but i абсолютно неприйнятний на при
туманними та
тому доглядати шию бути
проукраїнськими ст дурять деки експорту
відновлював атаку думка що сама 24
серпня україна ну ж парасольки туди руку до
місцю не знаю я kno знаю чим вже така
ціна йому нібито праворуч
пізно ця цінна публічна
інформації
лану таки думка поритий експортер гул і
нібито це стало ніби україна задала ну
там рану чипі зону могутній коливається
стає я така ну повернися щоб
означало для півострова для крім
давайте почнемо з того що я все-таки на
віско ви експерт пиріг
cz на ту мало щоб так глибоко аналізу
вати
у вас а машина лавочкина щоб означало
для людей ці все точно означало батьки
досить на краще знаки кисть башкова в
в тому числі в обранні російської
федерації не знав про шлях ти на
території України тому що кримська
mist стану на за 1 з 1 з
найважливіших за для ворда артерій по-і-до
і постачається через крим у тому числі
наш до техніка обрання так далі вісь з
травня потрібно літери краще знає не менше
метафорично таку цінність
кримський місць річку дон з
[музика]
брендів російського світу
які так науково візуал усміхався над
реалізувався по дну stand із цього зерна
на так званого російського світу screen геть
і дуже погано
вчилися у школі зокрема він і дуже
погано знає історію жадібно провину та курас
персоналу розпущеного тобто
російським парять за чи росія криму геть
вона вибираємо всі види б програмі ви
навіть пара нагадують протез скільки
рокерське до зустрічі він і не набирався
захисту українців доларами за воронами
крижаних кримських кримських татар бу
кораблі і ми самі себе називаємо
може їм самим і депортація my
російським переймаємо і я
рівненська спілка продовжу вашого напевно
політику один скутер займаний цих
точно стану, а ми будемо
сюди б розказано
чим на око харчування по догляду ви так
виріс погадала виготовили для dance
передове праве не віці на захищають
врятуй міллера кілька find розгадував
цю фразу загалом і хоче розповісти
історію одного народу то розкажіть
історію одні люди ця фраза якуб цю
історію розповіла, щоб подивитися тобі
в руку і
варто губи чоловіка я б
призначаючи на бій гордий стіл залучив
щоб я був в авто ранці і фрази лише
такі цілі стати і півроку ця цифра
потрібно тільки потрібно
просто ще раз перед жіночою рукою був
океан драматургом та владно житія та
досить часто ж тебе вище так і
сценарії щодо самих сценариста ви
можете налити його це вона приклад
з'явиться вб'ю за 1 раз, коли я правда ми
з колегами та друзями
творче у бідних
лівійських
сценаристів актуаріїв річки грубий
начальник на мене класний контент наша
без раши ще на передню дільницю
циліндри були
розмір голови і він і владно вже
написала сценарій цивіки пінний у машини
big
зниклі грамоти терпи всього день
та й за свою фабулу що два друзі
вирушає кудись інвестори 100 дол
за персонажами
я пішов читати сценарій ківан і
застрибнула прийшла ти і розроблятися
кіно ну навіщо було
і весело і
трохи я чим у нього жив у опції але
за над мов фантазії включив і
попрошу ван і вирушають на танку
так ну видатним би відповідаючи за
українських воїнів та за селян і там
пам'ятати про ідейну використовуватиму і я
на це до хитромудрих що він не ну
хлопці але я курси окей фантазія
художнику занатта хіба малі а я б ти
що наші фермери будуть
вібрато і втілив тони мирний зашибло
танки до обами - ви його ти що наша брат
і рому розбиратимуться у зброї
авіацію що
банку з-під саленки солоних озер kef
на ширинці збуватимуться б поїли
топ-топ сочі розкажи про те, що
ведуться і можна все
наші [ __ ] і ну до чого готовим хоч на
навряд чи будеш
ось він та все
можна сама йому сильно історія як
збулося і досить часто згадую
тимчасово з історія чи впораюся у
пані на vape манера
зараз у стильного промивання
викладаємо в неї вночі ми ж так і але
хлопці також знітився на вигляд лагодження
цьому спілкуюся попустяться
близько 11 ночі пугачова sms і прийшов на
телефон був написаний доступними планами на
медузу повернуться віпасани колли на
треба тільки Хелловін
по зоні спочатку знайомі такі на них
power це шоу смітимо ночі
триматися літаки на і чим ти потрібна
допомога ти
паршивець
так я знаю що
між нами зараз казковий дитячий
досить велика так тут
то було. але при близнюки я була до
квіткових баладу їх у машину вам вихід
з ви стали я написав так досліджуваного
вічно зажадають 9 я не сплю на закон
мура рівно 10 хвилин залишилося сказав що
вона зберігається я аріна замкомандира полку
азів
де їхня година живуть так спочатку дружин
чим можемо і він як ви знаєте у нас ціль
нас я ваш період життя але в тому що
досконалим у тому сідає кроку
нормативні україни
ще й караму
студент інших курсів alone i don't
вже
повністю професійні сини або як тому що
ми тільки мультики сьогодні vinzer був
дихає 20 по рації і вона була вам
розповім датами тихо молох може з ним
поговорити це кричу ваші страхи начебто
б
стані
не захочемо розгулятися збити комі тому
що але вище тисніть ставити їх вливань
це ж так ясна за голосом
великий коко медик вказавши вставляємо
студентам вчилася на розбавлятися
навіть ахтамар а я не вірю в те що цілі
шину на ваших сутичках
rostov
я сказав тиж
так
Доведи так непала творча людина тому
що
у творчому даю на пластини моментом
виглядають і т.п.
кращі тільки ти і нуб rename що люди так
сказав розсміятися силосу колір ми
там і
дуже немає руці у
горили чому питання project про
великими вирішив роботою важку операцію
ми доріжки побували у виконанні а
потім я не спав тому що для нації
під вартою командира та люди ну я
незнаю став хвилину телефону на пам'ятається
не так голову м'яза
натиснули і назибо чашок менше при клубі
люди різанини служить у тому числі і в армії
а в абсолютній своїми шістьма
з ним упевнений відпочивають і
бачиш на смуги мої поручи саму з
за собою і перед собою людей і
кетамін відпочиваючий дають приплив особі
класно я повинен відпочиваючий а історія
одного боку траху з розуму тому що він не
заразно знаємо за хостинг та азовстали ми
не знаємо про так замовником маріуполя
ось це ми знаємо оздоблені знаю куди
і сьогодні знаєш так і офіціали
окупанти школа штучок з робиш china
тим людям і здадуться ви слава богу ви
дно
ось у нас 15 рахунок війна стає цьому
штуцер виходу забудете рамкою з другом у
калюжу і пензлем потрібно дати завищується там
виросла борці повернутися до
історія від Едісон відпочивають про можуть
стражник у героїв танці пафосно над
грою та гарбуз ягід означав і так даних
елемента за розчиниться ви заявляєте
замкну один полицю
ось центр всього чого вона
поважаючи на звучання
потрібні і вижив і вам та ти хоч shop
максимум 100 що ви може так ти своїм
дедлайнам у тому числі й у плані
психологічної тут ринку
сам факт shaving процент думали у таких
умовах c свічки не нуб apparition відповідаючи
на високу професіонал підготовки на
дві чайної мотивації натомість кісток [ __ ] та
признач на сильний внутрішньої системи
координат поспішаю чару ручкою
ми не будемо ми завершимо це вже цю
трансляцію на такі мінськ на неї
позитивніше ноті і хотілося про обожнює про
нашому тоді ніж сама така з ті кістки
цілі духу
самого з такого бойового духу, щоб провину
нас зал і шансу щоб на них пострілу
виступила ті з нього і над вашу думку
харчування будь ласка давай дня наса
важливості та й артема
деталі всіх знаємо на закладеності
давайте на воду не забувати які
багаті цілі дав і наші
батьки наші батьки заклятого Шубін
владний бос мета даної за важливістю
що окремі закладіть цдл владного
самостійно реального вибору бідних людей
я бажаю вам мирного неба можу ризикового
якщо наші спини paramore
обожнюєш щоб і ми самі з гарбузом і наша
деталь обов'язково смугастим шивани
громадян україни та дегуніно були нібито
ви назвали чайному світлу та акіба волоки
sweet он і на ранок і новий своїх
емоціях у своїх знаннях щоб сама
половину нам відпущено було повним це і
тому що тут класно
забувають ще вивели не про свободу
вирішуйте свої країни своєї історії своїми
традиціями і кохання любити україна любить
людей слава україні слава україні героям
слава що не треба зараз по собі США
корисно травня нашим гостям довести
садовий душевний розмова на рік це
було в танці та табло і фактор же сер за
диска з граматики, якщо у вас права
пошуковий службу у вибраних сил України
і його пахана дар'я документ вже щось
покращилося a donation до всіх завдань
річці нас додалося ще раз десятому вас
більше актуальних новим
та тикових рапорту живий або доповідних
статей читайте на нашому сайті донька
белли українську від дівчини наші
репортажі на ю тубі і що зліва горнова
вам квіткового дня мирного неба та
доступних за зустріччю